dritter etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich jedes puncto das
vergessen leute wollt ihr ist ein
besonderer tag weil ihr seht es im
hintergrund wir haben jetzt endlich mal
ein bisschen mehr im hintergrund ja also
das ist jetzt noch nicht so viel aber
trotzdem immerhin etwas oder und ich
finde es gibt auch ganz gut aus ich habe
geplant dass ich noch ohne moos und
mache also halt ja müsste mal google
wenn ihr euch das nicht vorstellen könnt
ich finde dass sie total aus weswegen
ich auf der suche nach einer guten muss
man oder hat einfach so ein bild das
wird ja auch schon brechen
na ja darum sollst du nicht gehen heute
wir haben nämlich mal wieder was zum
auspacken ich kann auch verstehen wenn
jetzt leute sagen alex irgendwann rechts
zu ordner mit diese saturn und
mediamarkt scheiße macht doch mal wieder
was anderes und die absolut recht
deswegen wird auch nächste woche wieder
was anderes kommen also irgendwas was
bestellt welche ich mach das halt gerade
zu gern aber es wird cool das ist kann
ich euch schon versprechen wir haben
hier auch was besonderes und zwar haben
wir dass viele von euch auch beschrieben
es gibt aktuell einem smartphone
indischen von diesen sektoren
wundertüten ich habe mir gedacht das
wäre schade wenn ich das nicht mehr
testen deswegen gehe ich einfach zwei
bestellt haben einer davon kostet 499
euro x 2 899 890 euro also knapp 1000
euro habe ich bezahlt und jede box soll
smartphones im wert von 750 euro
erhalten das ganze mal zwei haben wir
smartphones im wert von 1.500
das ist nur eine box angekommen ich gehe
einfach mal davon aus dass sie das
zusammen gepackt haben weil irgendwie
konnte ich die nachfolgende sendung zu
machen so das war ein bisschen schade
wenn ihr jetzt um eine smartphone drin
ist habe ich ein problem weil das wäre
ein bisschen langweilig aber so schwer
wie diese box es auf jeden fall kein
smartphone deshalb wird das schon laufen
wird und das messer und rasiert und nein
das hat man auch keine scherze aber ich
muss mich noch ein bisschen rasieren
heute haben wir nur ein bisschen
bisschen nicht nachbauen zu hause leute
messer sind chart dass man sollte mit
messern vorsichtig umgeht und man sollte
messer auch nicht zu nahe ans gesicht
halten dann wollen wir das ganze mal auf
machen wir keine zweikämpfe das wäre
auch schade sonst könnte ja fast direkt
am rhein gucken
ach so und noch was ganz wichtig ist
leute immer habe ich jetzt gar nicht
gemacht aber immer vom körper weg
schneiden weil sie uns wenn man
abrutscht kann man sich schnell auch
selber verletzen
merkt euch stolz bin ich bin gerade auch
dabei war zwei youtube kanal ein
bisschen auch zu ziehen da gibt's dann
messer tricks tipps und tricks das soll
schon reichen und ihr seht wir können
das ganze öffnen
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt oder
soll man schön natürlich hier denn du
hast du oder leute was gedacht ich bin
gerade bei merlin im zimmer da alles gut
und merlin hat sich immer schon einen
höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch
gewünscht noch viel mehr als ich und
dann kam ich auf die idee lasse ich
ihnen doch diesen kleinen tisch hier in
seinem zimmer stellen damit er immer
schon so weiter zocken kann ich durfte
mir von flexi spot diesen geilen
komplett schwarzen tisch wir haben hier
schwarzes gestell wir haben eine
schwarze platte 180 ist der lang ich
kann euch hier gerne auch mit foto an da
gibt es ganz ganz viele verschiedene
konstellationen wie ihr euch euren
eigenen tisch zusammen bauen könnt und
leute was auch extrem geil ist ihr könnt
den ganzen tag trocken dann tut aber
natürlich irgendwann auch mal der rücken
weh und euch fehlt ein ähnlich muss auch
noch lernen kein problem wir stehen
auffahren den tisch ganz sanft ihr müsst
ihr schon mal einfach nur länger
vorhalten von den tisch kehrt nach oben
und schon könnt ihr euch gut durch
strecken und im stehen weiter lernen
leute ihr könnt den tisch sogar so hoch
waren dass ich limburg
unter jahren kann vor allem mit dem
schwachen pc und so findet das sehr gut
und das beste ist jetzt gibt es doch
eine krasse rabattaktion für euch und
zwar gibt es auf flexishop com könnt ihr
einfach auf die seite gehen verlinkt ihr
euch in der beschreibung vom 24 also von
heute bis zum 30 richtig krasse flash
angebote mit bis zu 37 prozent rabatt
ich kann euch versichern ihr werdet
nirgendwo so ein qualitativ guten
elektrisch verstellbaren schreibtisch
für so wenig geld finden vor allem noch
mit dem gutschein kommt die recht gut
weg deswegen checkt auf jeden fall mal
flexi spot ab danke für den tisch merlin
und ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem video alter okay ich kann
euch das dogma zeigen wir haben hier
drin
tatsächlich jetzt schon mal vier
verschiedene smartphones das hatten wir
gerechnet dass mal kurz runter
ok jetzt werde ich auch ein bisschen
nervös wir haben smartphones im wert von
1500 euro
das könnten ja theoretisch mindestens
mindestens vier iphone 8 sein oder
vielleicht auch ein iphone vielleicht
auch andere nicht sehen man muss ja
nicht immer nur ein apple denken auch
wenn ich hätte sehr gerne mag das hier
ist das erste hier noch das ist das
dritte und das vierte und das war's dann
auch schon also so viel haben wir heute
nicht zum auspacken aber einfach vier
handys lehmann hätte mir das jemand
gesagt als ich so in der sechsten klasse
war alex später du stehst du einfach und
kauft viel geiler dann ist auf einmal
kannst die ausparken junge ich hätte es
nie geglaubt man das ist sogar deswegen
leute verfolgt immer über träumen
irgendwann auch vier handys auf einmal
auszupacken
wir starten hier rein mit dem huawei
smart 2021 ok interessant leute die
rechtslage aber ich mache mir die nicht
an nur warte man kurz wie teuer ist das
im moment
okay ich hatte jetzt gedacht das ist ein
bisschen mehr wert aber es kostet hier
live
140 euro ja wohl besser ist nix dann bin
ich mal gespannt
dann müssten ja jetzt hier absolute
kracher drin sein weil von 1500 euro
sind wir noch weit entfernt oder es ist
tatsächlich so dass noch ein paket fehlt
ein schwer ist ein bisschen komisch weil
ich habe das schon vor über einer woche
bestellt nein wir haben das gleiche
nochmal das kann doch nicht sein oder
ok dann hat jemand dass man dazu bereit
280 euro dann müssen ja dass hier zwei
kasse handys drin sein oder es fehlt
halt auch was dann fehlt wahrscheinlich
war es wieder das thema ich bin da halt
irgendwie ein bisschen hin- und
hergerissen iphone ja aber ich bin
selbst schon sehen wir haben wieder
iphone 6 es in roségold 32 gigabyte neu
verpackt hat aber trotzdem dass er auch
kein kassenkreise natürlich ist es jetzt
nicht günstig aber was kostet so ein
ding 150 euro mehr wird das ja nicht
sein oder
die jungs halt lediglich kaum noch
originalverpackt weswegen man dafür
vielleicht trotzdem noch ein bisschen
geld bekommen ich will mal schätzen
ungefähr 200 euro also wir sind jetzt
insgesamt bei 480 euro von der damals 10
auf das letzte handy
wenn das jetzt kein iphone 12 ist dann
kommt irgendwie nicht hin und man kann
jetzt schon sehen die verpackung des
blau es ist kein iphone wir haben hier
eine art 72 das ist doch diese marke
wofür alle gaming youtuber werden oder
oder ab und macht auch nach obwohl
werben alles okay ich glaube schon sind
die denn so teuer dass so ein automat
72.000 euro kostet ich glaube ich also
das kostet auch 960 euro wenn wir das
dann erst mal zusammenrechnen landen wir
vor überschlagen bei 640 euro
wollt ihr mich verarschen weiter das
also sorry aber irgendwie bin ich sauer
selbst wenn jetzt so ein paket kommen
was ja offensichtlich noch fehlt ich
habe ja zwei bestellt sind wir halt mega
weit entfernt von 750 euro
naja leute ich muss das mal checken ich
bleibe euch das super gerne hier nochmal
ich habe zweimal das gleiche gestellt
ich hoffe das paket macht mir jetzt mal
heute oder morgen keinen plan
mittlerweile sind zwei tage vergangen
und wir haben es geschafft das paket ist
tatsächlich noch angekommen ich habe
mich schon bei ihnen beschwert weil von
denen kam halt keine antworten sind
irgend ein bisschen los und was mir das
ganze nochmal bestätigt hat dass die
bisher los ist dass ich einfach also
moment noch frisch ich habe ja zwei mal
das handy smartphone special paket
bestellt und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich glaube hier sind keine handys drin
das ist nämlich das liegt bestimmt zehn
kilo das ist irgendwie ein bisschen
dunkler also mein plan war halt wirklich
die beiden handy boxen zu bestellen hat
nicht so ganz funktioniert vielleicht
können wir das noch mal machen da gibt
es auch noch eine für 1000 für knapp
2000 euro
wenn wir hier auf dem video zehntausende
kunden bestelle ich die mal vielleicht
ist das ja interessant ansonsten reicht
um mit saturn vertreten
wir machen das erste mal vorsichtig auf
vielleicht sind ja gute sachen treffen
nur was ich wirklich sagen muss das ist
vom saturn ludwigsburg glaube ich die
geben sich wirklich mühe mit den
verpackungen kümmern hier steht somit
zum eee box drauf das hatten wir sonst
nie die jungen hat kein wunder dass das
so lange gedauert hat bis das angebot
wenn man sich so viel also wie haben die
das im eingepackt alter junge junge okay
gut hier haben wir schon mal einen
schönen der bürsten rolle ultimativen
sauberkeit fahrzeuge von ari geht kein
plan ist er kostet seht ihr hier
eingeblendet die smart phone box war ja
nicht nur moderat ja nur 640 euro wert
deswegen schauen wir mal wieder ein
bisschen wird mehr rausbekommen es kann
ja auch sein dass sie einfach nur noch
ein smartphone hat und weil das ist ein
sehr sehr großes smartphone und deswegen
hier nicht mit weiteren smartphones
dienen konnten und halt irgendwas
anderes getan haben ich weiß nicht was
ich auf jeden fall weiß ist dass sie
viel zu viel verpackungsmaterial haben
okay hier haben wir eine philips sony
care zahnbürste im paket ach so ja gut
keinen plan was das wert ist sich auch
hier ein gewinn
also sport nicht mehr machen
ok hier haben wir yamaha kopfhörer
wahrscheinlich so ganz moderne okay ihr
können wir schon vorstellen dass die
safe 300 euro kosten so wie die aussehen
wie ich glaube ich noch nie so eine
tolle kopfhörer verpackung in der hand
und dann haben wir vielleicht sind ja
jetzt hier die ganzen handys wird auf
die ich so lange gewartet habe oder es
ist halt einfach ein neuer soldos film
christa der kostet auch so 160 euro
glaube ich aber keine ahnung ich habe
mir irgendwie also ist mega schweigers
tag eine smartphone slim war
ich glaube die haben da irgendwas
verwechseln hey leute das ist wirklich
ein witz man ich könnte mich darüber
aufregen dass steht ich glaube wir
hatten ja in den angeboten mindestens
780 euro oder 750 euro was ja noch okay
es ist jetzt nicht so komplett krass wie
bei den anderen saturn es aber bei
smartphones wäre das in ordnung dann
ersten sich ein ganzes paket bekommen
das hat auch nur ein wert insgesamt
alles zusammen addiert von 640 euro also
darf ich wehre ich mich das geht ja
nicht bis jetzt auf jeden fall mit
abstand der schlechteste saturn oder
zumindest vom lieferumfang den ich
erhalten habe
trotzdem war das smartphone paket
halbwegs cool ich weiß nicht ob sich
dann nochmal für 2000 euro einzukaufen
vielleicht wartet ja nie was neues
angebot gibt aber ihr könnt ihr mal die
kommentare schreiben
ich danke euch für stu schon heute
abonniert super gern den kanal und kaum
ein handy wird wieder raus gehauen weil
ich bin ja so ne moment ist jetzt sechs
meter höhe ist aber das pure ps smart
2021 könnt ihr gewinnen einfach netten
kommentar schreiben und cooler zuschauer
von meinem kanal sein und den rest gibt
es auch lucky bonn.de er ist es heute
dank fürs zuschauen abonniert habe ich
schon gesagt
drei leute